the time has come for me
to lend my infinite
perfect wisdom on this planet
i there rio the game of would you rather
that's right we're doing another episode
of this on my own free will
not because i saw someone some other
youtuber recently make a video about it
and i'm like yeah those used to get
pretty good views
maybe i'll make another one of those but
you should be thanking me
okay my morals are absolutely perfect
okay let's begin this stupid game okay
would you rather become a superhero
or become a super villain to be fair
there's no cool super villain
there's very few of them they always
make them so lame
i think that's the problem with
superhero movies these days it's just
the villains are so lackluster
back in the day you know joker bane
badasses you know
what are they now sergeant birdman
sergeant squad fam bird
turtleman cat killer
nah i'll become a superhero easy moving
on oh and
please do uh leave your comments and
thoughts in the comments
in the comment section would you rather
be able to fly
or be able to breathe underwater what do
you think i'm some sort of [ __ ] fish
do i look like a fish to you if i can
fly then that means no effort
okay at least that's how i look at
flying if flying means i have to do this
all the [ __ ] time then now fam i
don't want to fly
okay i'll take the breathing underwater
i'll take the option where
i don't have to put any effort but if
flying just means hey
i would like to go there i'll take it
thank you easy can you get me some tiff
difficult
questions please this is too easy would
you rather
never be able to make a compliment
this is the easiest one i ever heard
why would i want to make a compliment
i'm trying to wrap my head around
never be able to compliment
that's supposed to be a bad thing i
don't or never be able to complain
well i think the choice is pretty
obvious
what
what what are you [ __ ] boys
77 don't want to complain what are you
[ __ ]
gay you never want to complain okay well
then you can't complain about this
you're a little [ __ ] how about that are
you gonna complain about it you can't
jesus christ would you rather never have
sex again
or never learn anything new
[Music]
well again the choice is obvious
masturbation
does that count of sex i changed my mind
i changed my mind
[ __ ] you would you rather be visited by
ancient aliens
or by mole p what the [ __ ] is mole
people
is that even a question that's
great great that's like asking someone
hey would you rather meet
the president or this homeless man i'll
be visited
by the mall people the people living in
our dirt and ground
instead of the ancient aliens that can
borrow earth
that can borrow to us ancient technology
which she
could save humanity no thank you i would
like them all
people i'll pick them all people
[Music]
would you rather be part of a real
giraffe
jurassic park scenario or
be part of a real day after tomorrow
scenario
jurassic park i was like would you like
to be cold for a couple hours or would
you like to be eaten by a bad ass
dinosaur
i'll i'll take the dinosaur would you
rather glue your eyes
shut with super glue or spill hot glue
over your naked lap easy
spill hot glue over my naked lap i've
done it a couple times it's a very
sexually
pleasuring experience i did it once by
accident
and then i'm like huh that was pretty
good would you rather live in a homeless
shelter
with internet access okay
or live an amazing house isolated from
any outside content
well you didn't say that i can't have
internet okay you just said no outside
contact
how amazing is this house you know does
it have a bowling alley
does it have a private helicopter
it's too vague i'm gonna have to go with
the homeless shelter well i guess you're
all a bunch of [ __ ] idiots huh
two percent of you are a bunch of idiots
congratulations
you want to live without pewdiepie
videos is that what you're trying to
tell me
moving on would you rather kill someone
yes oh wait
maybe i should read the whole thing and
have nobody know yes
or not kill someone but have everyone
think you did i'll just [ __ ] kill
someone
what are you stupid i thought about this
the other day
okay people say i will never kill anyone
but i'm like
no i think everyone will kill someone i
think it's in our blood okay
i think if if given the right
circumstance
you would kill someone okay if there was
a burn in front of you
and it said well if you don't kill this
guy all
the people in the world is going to die
okay you would kill it
anyone would kill with the right
circumstance okay
so don't [ __ ] [ __ ] me with that
[ __ ] i wouldn't kill anyone
yeah you would okay you would you would
i'd kill you for having shitty opinions
moving on
would you rather fight the entire smurf
village
or fight the full collection of care
bears what's the care bear
oh my god yes i would i would not just
fight them i would beat the [ __ ] out of
them and then when they're laying on the
ground i would
take down my pants i would unzip my huge
would you rather win an oscar or win the
or nobody price
[Music]
here's what the question is actually
saying uh would you rather
people look up to you and praise you and
love you
or would you actually like to help us
help society would you actually like to
do something good for humankind
but most people probably wouldn't give a
[ __ ]
would you rather have to wear a full
body red leotard
on your wedding day but that's what i
was planning to wear
thank you very much so what's a red
leotard
hell yeah can you imagine me and that
that looks sexy
or have to have the person you're
marrying
that day wear the full body red layer
tart so
marzia in a sexy red leotard or me in a
sexy red leotard
uh excuse me marcia i will have the
privilege
of looking hot in our wedding day okay
would you rather be best friends with
harry potter or be best friends with
katniss
everdeen who the [ __ ] is katniss
aberdeen
oh my god i don't want to be friends
with any one of these fat
i hated jane for lauren's before it was
cool okay
way before it was cool i saw through her
obnoxiousness
miles away her giant ego her oh look i
am
humble i am a little drunk right now
guys
i might say something totally crazy
i am jennifer lawrence please everybody
love me
look how beautiful i am look how humble
i am would you rather take a
sizzling hot shower or an ice cold
freezing shower
well i don't want permanent butt damage
to my body
so i'll pick the ice cold one because
i'm a swedish
viking man and not a little [ __ ] boy oh
it's a little cold
oh my balls went inside my body
that's normal okay it's called
masculinity
guess two percent are [ __ ] [ __ ]
how about that
congratulations would you rather slam
your hand in every door
or fall down every flight of stairs i
would rather die how about that which
one will most likely kill me the stairs
i'll pick that one thank you
well i guess i guess 515 000 people
are [ __ ] idiots god damn it pisses me
off though you're not paying attention
to my morals
you're picking the wrong you need help
you need guidance in your life stop
making bad choices bad choices kill
people
would you rather have a stylist do your
hair and makeup every day
or have a fashionista pick a new outfit
every day
i don't like when people dress me it was
really [ __ ] weird during a scare
pewdiepie
we had a she was very nice but her job
was to dress me
and i wasn't allowed to wear my own
clothes and it just really pissed me off
because i'm like oh you don't want any
form of authenticity
in this show you just want me to look
like a goddamn product
that you guys built i don't know why it
bothers me so much but
hair makeup do my hair and makeup i
don't give a [ __ ] okay well i guess 60
of people are [ __ ] wrong okay would
you rather always wear crocs or always
wear socks and sandals
can i pick both i love crocs okay have
you worn crocs
everyone hating on crocs like it's a
meme like you can't think for yourself
oh crocs are so ugly because that one
meme i saw online said it
they're [ __ ] comfortable as [ __ ] and
they say exact same thing
with sandals and socks okay oh i know
about them
you can't wear sandals and stuff i wear
sandals and socks
it's comfortable as [ __ ] you can't stop
me okay
oh you can't do it because someone else
said that you can't do it
god damn pissed me off [ __ ] you can't
think for that [ __ ]
you're not worthy of my practice you're
not worthy of my morals
[ __ ] you leave a like on this video by
the way appreciate it thank you so much
leave a like if you like crocs and leave
a like if you like sandals
this has been your boy